das ist der grünen politiker jürgen
trittin der uns jetzt zugeschaltet ist
und die schönen guten abend herr trittin
herr trittin sie sind in den vergangenen
jahren vor allem auch mit massiver
kritik gegen den botschafter hier und
jetzt ex botschafter richard greene l
wahrgenommen worden wie haben sie jetzt
seine pressekonferenz dort erlebt er war
einmal ein guter botschafter für donald
trump er hat sehr gut
zu diesen präsidenten gepasst und wenn
ich ihn loben sollte dann würde ich
sagen es war besser
jemand der wie er in dieser form
klartext redet ihr zu haben
da wusste man wie donald trump denkt und
insofern war er schon passend zu diesem
präsident jetzt hat unser kolumnist
alexander von schönburg gesagt habe mit
einem freund von donald trump gesprochen
der sagt man solle donald trump nie
unterschätzen und immer dann wenn man
wettet er verliert ist genau anders rum
kommt wie ist ihre analyse glauben sie
er hat eine chance mit dem was er da
gerade macht also erstens er ist
unterschätzt worden
gerade in der mobilisierungsfähigkeit
wir müssen heute zur kenntnis nehmen joe
biden ist der kandidat der in der
geschichte der usa
die meisten stimmen jemals für sich hat
erobern können donald trump liegt zwar
drei millionen hinter ihm aber er ist
fast so stark wie der bisherige
rekordhalter der von ihm ja nicht
besonders beliebte und geschätzte barack
obama
das heißt viele auch umfragen haben
offensichtlich die fähigkeit donald
trumps und des republikanischen lagers
zu mobilisieren
unterschätzt von daher kam die
diskussion über lenz neid ich persönlich
war da immer eher skeptisch weil ich das
beim letzten mal erlebt habe nur am ende
wird man über die frage reden müssen wer
hat wie abgestimmt so ist das in der
demokratie und der versuch die
auszählung und die zählung von stimmen
von menschen die gewählt haben
unter den bedingungen die zu dem
zeitpunkt galten nicht zu zählen das ist
in der tat demokratisch nicht
darstellbar das ist ein angriff auf die
dinge aber wie bewerten sie die vorwürfe
die es dort jetzt gibt trittin l hat
diese pressekonferenz gehalten da war
davon die rede dass möglicherweise tote
gewählt haben können gleichzeitig wurden
menschen präsentiert die gesagt haben
dass sie an der abgabe ihrer stimme
gehindert worden sind das nicht
ernsthafte vorwürfe sind das nicht dinge
die man jetzt ernst nehmen muss dafür
gibt es dafür wirklich ja gerichte so
etwas zu beurteilen
steht mir aus der entfernung nicht zu
dieses zu tun
ich muss nur darauf hinweisen
dass die beobachter der wahlen die
übrigens auch in anderen auch teilweise
sehr autokratischen system diese wahlen
beobachtet haben nämlich die beobachter
wahlbeobachter der osze im wesentlichen
von einer sehr sauberen ablauf dort
gesprochen haben und wenn man mal zur
kenntnis nimmt und das rutscht dann so
ein bisschen bei richard greene l hinten
runter wie viele menschen zur wahl
gegangen sind wie viele menschen von
ihrem recht gebrauch gemacht haben dann
redet er möglicherweise oder versucht er
einen großen erfolg der demokratie der
an diesem dritten november in den usa
stattgefunden hat schlecht zu reden
indem er behauptete oder auch belegte
störung auflistet die diejenigen die
erfahren in solchen fragen und übrigens
neutral
anders als rich and green day nicht
festgestellt haben er tritt ihn jetzt
sprechen sie gerade wahlbeobachter der
osze an die haben gestern auch schon
scharfe kritik an donald trump geäußert
und uns gerade gesagt normalerweise
kennen wir das aus anderen staaten nicht
aus dem land of the free aber zu den
gerichtlichen prozessen die jetzt gerade
ablaufen wie groß ist ihre sorge dass
wenn wir dann wahrscheinlich heute nacht
ein ergebnis haben dieses eigentlich
noch gar nichts bedeutet weil der
tatsächliche kampf vor den gerichten
dann erst richtig losgeht
ja ich meine in dem punkt hat ja recht
donald trump hat in allen fragen wo er
jemals in die schwierige situation
geraten ist weil er mal wieder einen
konkurs hingelegt hat weil er seine
schulden nicht bezahlen konnte
immer den weg durch die instanzen
gewählt immer in der hoffnung dass am
ende entweder über einen vergleich traf
häufig ein- oder über die ermüdung der
gegenseite dieses passiert ich glaube
aber dass die logik der aus seinen
geschäftlichen gerichtsprozessen hat
auch diese situation nicht zu übertragen
ist
die über 70 millionen menschen die zu
beiden gewählt haben werden nicht
ermüden und diese strategie die da ist
wird nicht funktionieren
und ein vergleich gibt es auch nicht
das ist wie beim highlander es kann nur
einen geben und nur einer kann präsident
werden jetzt noch einmal konkret die
frage wie groß ist ihre sorge dass
donald trump egal welches ergebnis geben
wird nicht freiwillig aus dem weißen
haus ausziehen wird
er hat gesagt er wird als er sei ein
schlechter verlierer
selbsteinschätzung der will ich jetzt
mal nicht widersprechen ich glaube aber
dass die institutionen in den fahrrad
die institutionen in den vereinigten
staaten haben wir sehr schwierigen
situationen bewiesen wie sie
funktionieren und insofern wird es nicht
von donald trump und seiner bereitschaft
abhängen sondern diese wahl wird am ende
durch die wählerinnen und wähler
entschieden sein und daran werden auch
gerichte nichts ändern was ich fürchte
es etwas ganz anderes das durch die
delegitimierung von solchen verfahren
durch das schlechtreden dieser wahl
tatsächlich kräfte auf den
plan gerufen werden wie sie
beispielsweise jetzt schon in arizona zu
sehen waren die sich mit waffen und
bewaffnet und maskiert vor wahllokale
bestellt haben das ist eine entwicklung
die dem demokratischen und friedlichen
charakter dieser wald in keiner weise
gerecht wird
solche kräfte im mund hat zu haben das
ist in der tat etwas was ein präsident
nicht tun darf
vielen dank jürgen trittin dass sie
heute abend hier mit uns gesprochen
haben wir sind bild und wir liefert dir
deine news auf youtube zum nächsten
video kommst du hier und vergesst bitte
nicht unseren kanal zu abonnieren